all right Italy yes Italy uh first off
how do you get the name of Italy as far
as I know my dad named me it's your
given name right my given name from you
know yeah i t a l i tell me about your
family growing up
we run up uh my earliest memory I could
uh remember was uh
me and my mom you know she's she she's a
Sagittarius she's done the best she
could as far as uh me and her you know
making it and stuff she's um
she's a good mom you know she did the
best she could but my dad was the one
that kind of [__] up you know
um
a child was shaky but I mean you know as
far as my mom and dad were concerned um
it was a lot of uh like uh
they were a lot of fighting a lot of
fighting and abuse you know as far as uh
you know with my my mom and dad um
you know uh
they fought a lot
my dad was controlling he was uh
supposedly bipolar whatever and uh
uh he would uh beat up my mom and lock
me in the closet while he beat on her
and all I can remember is uh
like um
taking my hand under the closet door and
doing this as far as uh
you know
anyway
um
yeah that's about it I mean that's not
it but you know any abuse
that you you received
yeah I mean locking locking me in the
closet so my dad heated and
necessarily
hit me
he pushed me in closets and locked me in
there you know he kidnapped me a couple
times and uh
um I can remember going to court
actually for a time where he uh
took me you know and uh
for a long period of time but I didn't
know what was exactly happening you know
so
I just um knew I want my mom
but no abuse no sexual abuse something
like that not from my father no
from somebody else yeah sexual abuse
from the babysitter's son
that's as far as I can remember I mean
uh he was I was four years old he was
about maybe like nine or ten years old
um I'm pretty sure he got
sexually abused too you know
um
uh I'm in the room my mom used to drop
me off for babysitting because my mom
would work a lot
even now she likes to work
um
you know uh
and uh he was uh I was in the room
watching cartoons and he'd come up and
you know
you know like uh
stuck his penis in my mouth you know I
was about three or four years old
but I still remember this that's my
earliest sexual memory as far as I know
did I continue or is this one time
uh make a team for a little while
um
but then it stopped after I started
showing signs of um
of um
some weird signs because I started to uh
abuse animals and do weird stuff and uh
my mom she uh
she something happened and I guess my
mom pulled me out of the situation
what kind of kid were you in high school
High School
ah [__]
I was in and out of high school
thankfully I was a high school dropout
but I graduated though uh but anyway uh
in and out of high school I used to sell
drugs and you know I sold sold uh sold
uh weed ninth grade year
I can remember uh
when I was in ninth grade I my mom was
having problems with me and um she
actually had me go and visit with my
father
and um
he uh in L.A or whatever and he uh
he decided to go berserk or whatever and
act like a [__] or whatever and um he
choked me out and um
he but
the weirdest thing is when he would
leave
um the house he would lock me in his
house you know like had these latchkeys
I was about 13 and he would have these
these uh I don't know he locked me
inside to where I couldn't get out while
he was gone
and um
anyway uh there's one point of time
where
I uh
I was like okay well
um I'm gonna wash my clothes my clothes
were on the ground he grabbed me by my
uh by my collar and he was like I want
to throw you through the window and
finally I got a taste of how he was you
know as far as um
being uh
um
you know uh in the team in my teenage
years preteens or whatever
your dad using drugs no as far as I
don't know he was just uh
bipolar
yeah he's had he's he has three
businesses
hopefully if he sees this hello Dad
Daryl Jones I'm his first born and I
look just like him
your adult life you spent where you've
been on the streets
actually my story is a little bit
different
it's a little bit new
um
I start my best to actually stay off the
streets you know what I mean but um as
far as I'm concerned like you know I was
homeless you know uh from 2012 to about
2015 like I said during that time you
know it was just me and my ex-wife you
know we were on the streets you know we
lost our place and you know we were on
the streets till then and then it
brought us here to Skid Row when we came
here
um we uh she [__] up and you know
started she started cheating on me and
had another kid's baby or whatever and
you know that kind of broke us apart and
then um from there I mean you know but
throughout that whole relationship you
know since I knew her we had a drug drug
addiction
um we were Addicted to You Know crystal
meth
and um it's been a fighting battle
yeah I mean you are born female yes but
you are
transgender trans man but you know the
thing is I don't really trip off the
pronouns and all that [__] you know
I'm not I'm just who I am you know what
I mean um but uh
you know it is what it is you think the
sexual abuse that you went through is a
four-year-old had anything to do with
that has nothing to do you think you're
born this way
uh yes yes as far as yeah
but as far as I know that I'm female but
you know what I mean you know but as far
as with the mindset I can remember back
since I was like at least four years old
you know but it could have been some
type of
um oh look at that you know what I mean
or I'm like that you know growing up I
knew I was female but you know it's like
uh
it's kind of it's kind of hard to
explain but I don't want to get all into
that
but I know the truth though I know I'm
female it is what it is but
I just choose to live my life this way
you know how do you support yourself
um I get um
SSI
and um I take jobs here and there like
under the table jobs you know like doing
construction or whatever or I go to
school
you know
would you like to be in five years
five years where would I like to be
um
I'm not too sure
I like to be away from this area moving
out moved out of state
yeah do you have any regrets in your
life
um
kind of in a way but I can't really yeah
I guess you could say yeah
what's your biggest regret uh not
listening to my mom as far as um
uh staying
in school and you know while I was in
school I graduated high school like I
said but as far as figuring out what I
wanted to know as far as uh my career
goals and [__] like that
and making a point of uh you know
accomplishing and accomplishing them
you know
yeah
your your relationship with your dad is
is it always non-existent non-existent
right now it is I like to uh
hopefully maybe he sees it he sees this
video and reaches out to me
Italy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
uh
the ones you love mean the most and um
to uh always well
follow put yourself first in a
non-selfish way but put yourself first
as far as um your goals and dreams and
uh and the ones that you love they mean
the most to you and just remember that
at the end of the day
you know
all right Italy thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah cool thank you
wish you the best of luck thank you
thank you